welcome to saw's talks money where all
we talk is money i'm your host adam
sosnick and i'm here
to help you build your wealth and to
save
that money on today's episode we're
going to be breaking down the 10 things
that are killing your wealth let's talk
money
all right so let's start with this off
top i want you
to win with money i started this whole
show with one reason
to help people get smarter with money i
had to learn this stuff the hard way all
right
so what's the problem in america today
the problem in america today
is this everybody's trying to keep up
with the joneses all right
now i don't know the joneses i'm not
trying to keep up with the joneses i'm
not trying to even keep up with the
kardashians all i'm trying to do is keep
up with myself
and my wealth now did you know that the
average american will make between one
and two million dollars in their
lifetime did you know that so making
money is not the
problem spending money is and what's at
the heart of this problem
it's this we buy things we don't need
with money we don't have
to impress people we don't even like is
this a problem you have this is a
problem a lot of americans have
so here's the deal i'm going to ask you
a question ready ready would you rather
look rich
or be wealthy would you rather look rich
or be wealthy that's a question i had to
ask myself over 10 years ago when i
actually started making
money and i said give me option b be
wealthy
so today we're going to go over 10
things that are absolutely killing your
wealth
and by the end of this hopefully you're
going to get smarter with money
understand where your money's going and
start focusing on your net
worth all right now so let's jump into
these 10 wealth
killers all right wealth killer numero
uno it's at the top of the list that's
your car i'm sorry to tell you if you're
a car guy
i got some bad news for you now here's
the deal if you google
wealth killer you know what's going to
pop up
cars top of the list now for me cars are
definitely the most
overrated purchase you can possibly make
i actually went all throughout my
building i live in a pretty expensive
building
cars galore maseratis ferraris corvettes
galore
just collecting dust you can't leave
your house right now
due to corona and i went through and i
saw how much money people were spending
on these depreciating assets it's crazy
why is a car the number one wealth
killer let's break it all down right
here
this is a long list i don't know if i'm
gonna read all this you got car payments
you got car insurance you got finance
charges you got down payments
you got tax tag title you got
maintenance you got upkeep accessories
modifications
when you want to put tints on the car
you want sound systems in your car
you want all these upgrades to your car
to look fresh and look dope
but it's just costing you money and that
my friends here's the catch here's the
rub
that's if everything goes according to
plan how many times have you had a car
where everything has
just gone according to plan no aunt that
never happens
why is that because you're always going
to have something that goes wrong
flat tire someone backs into you you're
getting an accident
you know tickets god forbid you get
towed god forbid you get a dui
all of a sudden your car just turned
into an absolute
financial disaster now here's the deal
let's jump right into the numbers so you
can understand
where we're coming from you don't
believe me let's check the facts average
new car in america today costs 37
000 compare that with a used car that's
20 grand
average car payment in america for a new
car 550 bucks
what that's the average for a new car in
america
that is your money driving away used car
that's 390 bucks now if you say hey look
i just like to lease man i don't buy
cars i just lease my car
average lease payment 450 bucks now
here's the catch with the lease
you got a lease that's a payment for
life every two or three years you get a
new fancy ride
but that's payment that's payment that's
payment every single year of your life
now here's the deal
depreciation a car is a depreciating
asset did you know that did you know
that cars go down in value as you drive
it down the road first year of a new car
it'll go down 30
so if you bought a car 37 000
depreciates 30
the first year after that it's a used
car then it starts to depreciate 15
per year after five years of having a
car your car will depreciate
60 percent 60
depreciating asset let me just give you
some final numbers here
you buy a new car that's 37 000 5 years
later
that car is worth 15 000 not a good
investment
used car you buy it for 20 g's five
years later that's worth
eight thousand dollars you think this is
a good look not a good look so here's my
final piece of advice when it comes
to having a car the game has changed
when people were driving cars all
throughout america you had to have a car
it was a need now a car is a luxury
now a car is a want now what do i mean
by that now
in america today we got lyft we got uber
people are working remote you don't have
to show up to an office every day
you got options so here's what i'm
trying to tell you when you have a car
versus not having a car three words do
the math do the math i brought a buddy
of mine into my studio to see how much
he was spending on his car he had no
idea
that what he thought was a 20 000 car
was actually costing him
forty thousand dollars so like i said do
the
math you thought you were buying this
car for 18
putting down two and financing 16. so
you're thinking you're spending
around 18 g's did you have any idea you
were spending 40 on this
uh no i did not how much is your car
actually costing you
versus how much could you save not
having a car let me help you out and
give you some quick numbers
the average annual cost of a car today
is 8 500
that's if like i said before everything
just goes according to plan
right you got car insurance average car
insurance in america today
1750 bucks so the game has changed
do the math your car is the number one
wealth killer
wealth killer number two we're talking
about fashion
fashion ever heard of it i live for
fashion people
love their fashion what are we talking
about with fashion it's clothes
shoes purses jackets accessories
belts stop stop stop focusing
on trends stop focusing on labels stop
focusing on the brand names
start focusing on just your fit what
makes you feel good
and being comfortable in your own skin
let's break down the most expensive
brands you can spend your money on you
got your gucci gang gucci gang gucci
gang
you got lui prada fendi versace versace
versace i come to the mention i stay in
miami
you got delta gabbana armani hermes
supreme is that still even a thing
polo tommy burberry and guess and guess
what like i said before the most
important thing you can be
is comfortable in your own skin one of
my favorite memes out there i love it i
love it i love it
it's a picture of warren buffett one of
the richest men in the world and bill
gates one of the other richest men in
the world and it says
156 billion dollars in one picture
and not a gucci belt in sight all right
you don't need a gucci belt to feel rich
just save that money and just do you now
one of my favorite songs is about a
rapper called mclemore let me know if
you ever heard this song about
i be popping tags only got 28 in my
pocket
there's a famous line in that song he
goes one man's trash that's another
man's come up now i'm not saying you
need to shop
at the thrift store right but there's
some sick deals in there i don't know if
you've been to a thrift store but the
biggest thing is that understanding
their clothes
that fashion they're depreciating assets
if you're not wearing them
they're in your closet they're taking up
space costing you money
you can get it at the thrift store these
days with corona there's a lot of fancy
clothes in your closet you can't even
wear
can't even wear i'd rather have the cash
so understand something
156 billion dollars in a photo no gucci
belt in sight
keep that in mind wealth killer number
three jewelry
now when i think of jewelry
unfortunately i've been ingrained
because of hip-hop
to think of that bling-bling every time
i come around your city bling-bling
a pinky ring worth about 50 bling bling
50 000
on a pinky ring i don't know about that
lil wayne so hip hop has
changed the culture when it comes to
jewelry how many times you see somebody
walk around they got gold chains they
got earrings they got grills in
they're just iced out they're dripping
wasting money y'all
wasting money jewelry is a depreciating
asset i'm not sure if you knew that
you spent a hundred thousand dollars on
a jeweler you're not getting that
hundred thousand dollars back i
guarantee you that so in hip-hop it's
all about this gold chain what's up with
that what's up with that i actually
interviewed a dude i said you came
across five thousand dollars
what's the first thing you do and he
goes man i'll get myself a gold chain so
if you get a check for five grand what
are you doing with that five grand this
month what's up
i said damn that's the first thing
you're doing when you get five thousand
dollars you said yeah
hip-hop love you love your lyrics bad
messages when it comes to money and when
it comes to jewelry so here's the most
important thing to understand with
jewelry
it is not an investment it is simply a
status symbol
that more than likely depreciates and
the last thing that you should
understand
is just be you you don't need jewelry to
be the cool guy you don't need to be
popping ice in order to look good just
be
you understand that maybe you have one
watch that's cool for a guy you have a
watch you're good that's a jewelry you
have
maybe you have a necklace no big deal
but you don't need a watch you don't
need a necklace a jewelry
earrings grill like you don't need all
that just be
you save that money wealth killer number
four
eating out and ordering in quick little
stats real quick according to the bureau
of labor
right the average american household
will spend three
thousand dollars a year dining out that
is your money
literally being flushed down the toilet
all right you see what i did there that
breaks down to about 250 bucks a month
of just eating out and ordering in so
the average meal
will cost you four dollars if you cook
at home the average meal if you eat out
will cost you thirteen dollars that's a
nine dollar difference
it's five times more expensive to order
in than it is to cook at home
five times so you know who knows this
you know who knows this the delivery
apps
how many times have you ordered from
doordash grubhub ubereats postmates bite
squad
they want your money they want you
staying home and ordering in they don't
want you to learn how to cook what i
want you to do
learn how to cook learn how to make some
eggs make a bowl of cereal if you need
to
all right i'm not saying you need to be
chef emeril lagasse or something like
that
but just learn how to cook it's okay to
treat yourself every once in a while i'm
not saying you can't
ever eat out that'd be ridiculous but
start to focus on more special occasions
of eating out
maybe a date maybe it's something you
want to celebrate but not
every single night of the week every
single day for lunch you can't be doing
that
speaking of lunch case example if you go
out to lunch
every single day you go to work you work
five days a week ten dollars a day
that's 50 a week you're spending on
lunch you extrapolate that
times 52 weeks a year that's over 2500
you're spending just on lunch if you
just bring your lunch to work though at
least cut that
in half save that money number five
wealth killer
smoking talk about your money literally
going up in smoke not a good look let's
break down the three things that people
are spending their money on
when it comes to smoking number one
cigarettes average pack of cigarettes
today cost 6.20 if you're a pack a day
smoker that's 188
a month that's 2 200 a year
and if you just can't quit smoking over
10 years you just spent 22 g's
now people are smoking jewels these days
right never smoked a jewel in my life i
don't know but apparently a device costs
just as an entry fee to walk into the
door of smoking jewels
just to get started a four pack of
pauses 15.99
that adds up to 180 a month pretty much
the same as smoking
now all my weed heads out well yeah
where my weed heads at
apparently the average consumer spends
650 dollars a year
hitting that blunt now here's the deal a
quarter of people spend
one to two thousand 000 of their
hard-earned money
of their green on the green one of the
things i always say is health is wealth
so if you're a smoker you're coughing
you're not feeling so good you're high
you're lazy all day
what's that doing for your productivity
what's that doing for your wealth your
health is your wealth
and that's your money up in smoke wealth
killer number six
is drinking and getting wasted
all right here's the deal there's three
levels of drinking three places that you
typically would drink at right you drink
at home
right little house party little do your
thing at the house
you go to the bar local pub no big deal
or you go all up in the club bottle full
of bub mama i got what you need
here's the deal let's break down where
these three levels of drinking come in
how much it's costing you and the three
types of drinks
that you might drink all right so number
one you got beer number two you got wine
and number three you got liquor is
quicker right so an average
cost of you know bringing a case of beer
home you want to bring a six pack a 12
back
you know 10 bucks maybe you're a pbr
kind of a person only costs you two
bucks you save that money
wine average bottle of wine cost you 15
average bottle of liquor
25 just drink it at home that's what
it's going to cost you between 10
and 25 now you want to step out you want
to do your thing you want to hit the
streets
you want to go to a bar now we're going
to talk about paying a premium
a markup price and what that comes out
to so now let's say i bought
let's say a beer is two dollars right
two dollars that's what it's gonna cost
to bring a beer home now if you're gonna
have a beer in a bar that's a 300 to 400
markup
that's six to eight dollars for that
beer right glass of wine that's a markup
of 150 to 350 percent
and liquor if you're gonna have a drink
or a cocktail at the bar that's a 300
to 450 markup just for the opportunity
to sit at a bar and have a drink no big
deal
now if you want to hit the club baby you
want to be all up in the club scene
now let's break down what it's going to
cost you to be all up in the club
like 50 cent average bottle of club is
350 dollars
to 575 dollars for each bottle that is a
thousand percent markup of what it would
typically cost you
if you just wanted to buy a bottle of
liquor and take it home now if you've
ever been in a club
i used to be all up in the club i've
spent my fair share in the club we could
roll the tape on that
now if you did not know this you are not
paying for the liquor you are paying for
what the real estate you want to be in a
prime
location in the club you want to be seen
you want to be all up in the mix there's
a premium for that and that premium is
thousand percent so when i was broke as
a joke and i was at 20 something and i
had no money in my life
and i wanted to go out in the club
little hot tips i'm not saying you
should do this but this is what i did
i would roll with a girl she would bring
a bottle in her purse bring it to the
club next thing you know we got a bottle
in the club i'm not saying you should do
that
but that's what we did what i would do
sometimes i would hold a flask take sips
save that money so understand that
drinking at home
versus at a bar versus all up in a club
there's different price ranges for this
so understand what you're getting
yourself into when you step out
and try to hit the seat wealth killer
number seven
is gambling with your money now if
there's number one rule with gambling if
you did not know this you're about to
learn this now and that is this
the house always wins now what does that
mean you might be gambling and in the
short term
you're playing blackjack you're playing
poker you're playing craps you have the
slot machines
you might be up in the short term but in
the long term
the house always wins so their goal at
the casino
right is to keep you there as long as
possible so what do they do there's no
windows
there's no sunlight it's dark it's smoky
they're giving you free drinks they want
you get a little
you know tipsy and tore up next thing
you know your inhibitions are a little
low
and you're gambling you're losing money
now how much does the average person
lose
when they go gambling well i'll tell you
right now between 500 and 600
a year that's your money now that's not
a lot of money that's not crazy
but now let's talk about if you're
addicted to gambling right so for my
addicted gamblers out there these might
be some
uncomfortable truths so the average
amount of the debt for someone who's
addicted to gambling is between 55
dollars and ninety thousand dollars
that's a lot of dope
now you ladies are a little bit better
the average lady who's addicted to
gambling that's only fifteen thousand
and here's an uncomfortable truth twenty
percent of compulsive gamblers
end up filing for bankruptcy so be smart
with your money so it's okay to go to
vegas for a weekend
have a good time spend a little dough
but don't fall into that gambling trap
now speaking of a gambling trap let's
talk about the lottery everybody wants
to play the lottery everybody wants to
be a millionaire
let's talk about what happens when you
play the lottery now here's a number
the average person in america will spend
225 dollars a year
on the lottery that's not crazy that's a
dollar a day that's nothing crazy here
less than a dollar a day actually here
are your odds of winning the lottery and
just living the good life
one in three hundred million one in
three hundred million
now if you don't know how tough of odds
those are let's talk about some other
things and just break that down
so the odds of you being in a plane
crash one and eleven million
the odds of a shark attack one in 3.75
million
the odds of you getting struck by
lightning one in two million and the
odds of you making it to the nba
one in 3 500. so what does that mean you
have a greater odd
of being an nba player making it to the
nba in a plane that's struck by
lightning
and a plane crash than you are to win
the lottery so if your get rich quick
scheme is to win the lottery
you got another thing coming wealth
killer number eight
just being a good old-fashioned american
couch potato
now according to nielsen the average
american will watch
five hours of tv a day now what does
that mean
five hours a day that's 35 hours a week
that's 77 days a year
that's 20 of your life of being a couch
potato so you know who knows this you
know who knows you love sitting around
doing nothing watching tv
well all the following options and i'm
gonna have to take a breath to read all
this
but you got tv cable directv netflix
hulu
amazon prime crackle hbo mac cbs all
access
you got 2b disney plus apple tv fandor
quivi and now the latest is you got
peacock by nbc
that's a lot of tv y'all now i guarantee
you there's somebody out there in
america unfortunately
that has all that i gotta have my shows
i gotta have my tv
i'm just home doing nothing sitting on
the couch
now just add to that the average
american will spend
seven hours a week playing video games
and on top of that the
the average video game console is
between two and five hundred dollars the
average game cost 60 bucks then you got
your in-app purchases
just spending money sitting in front of
a tv
watching tv playing video games instead
of spending your time
invest your time maybe that's reading
maybe that's working out
maybe that's starting a business the
number one thing that i did
rather than sit in front of a tv i used
to love football
every sunday of my life football
football football i said you know what
no more football for me and what did i
do
i started this money show with that
extra time so imagine what you can do if
you take
five hours a day back of stopping
watching tv
number nine being in the wrong
relationship now let me tell you
something
i've spent more money on all this stuff
right here
being in the wrong relationship now
let's break down some
of the numbers that goes behind being in
the wrong relationship right so the
average amount of partners a man will
have in his life apparently is 7.6
compared to women that's 2.6 now i don't
know about you men tend to brag
women tend to keep their things a little
bit close to the vest secret but i don't
know what do you think
men seven women 2.6 you think that's
high you think that's low
what do you think average relationship
in america today lasts
two years nine months have you had a
relationship last longer than three
years
then you're beating the odds right there
the average american will spend hundred
and twenty
thousand dollars in their lifetime on
dates
and then being in the dating world
that's a lot of dough the average
wedding costs
today thirty four thousand dollars the
average engagement ring
sixty three hundred dollars now why
should you understand all these numbers
before you get married
is this 50 of all marriages in america
today
end in divorce 50 so that means this
flip a coin on whether your marriage
will actually work or not work
i don't like those odds so what are
people understanding that they might
need to do
in order to prepare for those odds well
of millennials are actually getting
prenups these days what do you think
if you're getting married would you do a
prenup would you sign a prenup would you
ask your partner to sign a prenup
these are things that are happening
today flip a coin whether you're gonna
get divorced or not
now you might be asking what's the
average length that people stay married
you might have heard of the seven year
itch after seven years people say i
don't know i don't know if i can do this
anymore
well apparently in year eight they have
their answer right there that's the
average amount of time
that people stay married in america now
if you're gonna get divorced the average
divorce will cost you
thirteen thousand dollars that's just in
lawyer fees and in court fee
that's not to mention alimony and child
support and all the other stuff you
might have to get into
so being in the wrong relationship not
only may you end up being
heart broken you might end up being
heart broke
you see what i did there so choose
wisely before you start spending your
time
your money and your heart on the wrong
person
all right now it's time for wealth
killer number 10 which is just going
shopping it used to be that the favorite
american pastime was baseball
now it's just going to the mall so let's
break down the definition
of shopping right so shopping the
definition is to visit places
where goods are sold in order to look
and buy things that's just shopping for
you right so when it comes down to
shopping is
consumerism materialism and just good
old-fashioned
spending money on stuff right so i'm not
saying you need to be a minimalist
but that might be something you need to
look into these days after doing all
this stuff
so how often do you go to the store and
say all right i'm just going into target
i'm gonna get one item and
i'm gonna head out next thing you know
you got a whole shopping cart full of
stuff
that's america today so what does all
this shopping and materialism lead to
well that leads to debt here's some
numbers for you the average credit card
debt in america today 5700 bucks the
average household debt in america today
a hundred and thirty seven thousand
dollars talk about shop
to your drop now if you like this video
hit that like button and if you have not
seen my video on how to win the money
game please check that out right here
and if you have not subscribed to
valuetainment economics
please click right here and subscribe
and as always
save that money